ALEX DANILO: Hi!
I'm Alex Danilo from the Google
Developer Relations team.
One of the things I found
really hard as a web developer
is making compelling
animations on a site.
It seems easy enough at first
to throw some CSS animations
onto a site, and then watch the
browser fly stuff around you,
and you feel all chuffed
when you first see it.
But if you're like me, you
want to make your site really
stand out, you
know, be memorable.
Not just another pre-canned
clone of something people
have already seen.
So I started experimenting
with different web animation
techniques, and right
away hit problems
with doing fancy things.
For example, I wanted to
make two things animate
in perfect sync, but
couldn't find a way
to do it really easily.
My solution took 1,000 lines
of code, was extremely choppy,
and riddled with jank.
If only there was a better way.
Now this is the kind of
thing I wanted to build,
a 3D [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]
view of the world,
with silky smooth jank-free
animation, and total control.
Well, now there is a better way.
A bunch of browser writers
and animation experts
got together a
couple of years ago
to look at this with a fresh set
of eyes, lots of eyes, in fact.
We spent a lot of
time discussing
what web developers need,
how animation designers work,
and a whole lot more.
What we came up with
is Web Animations 1.0.
We aim to take all the
existing web animation
primitives out there,
and unify them.
And also bring new
capabilities that weren't just
more powerful, but would
run faster and smoother
as a result.
Now one of the best APIs to play
with animation from JavaScript
is, of course,
requestAnimationFrame,
especially if you want
to fine-grained control
of everything that's happening
on a frame-by-frame basis.
So let's take a quick
look at how animation
works when you use
requestAnimationFrame.
Now using requestAnimationFrame
gives great control,
but forces JavaScript
execution on every frame.
Now this is fine if you're not
doing much in your JavaScript.
But we only have 16
milliseconds for each frame.
And that includes paint
and layout time, too.
So if you run out of time,
you know what happens?
Skipped frames,
resulting in jank,
which some people call jitter.
Now this is the main
reason it's a good idea
to decouple the animations from
JavaScript execution itself.
So we wanted the
flexibility of control
from JavaScript,
but not the jank.
And so this is what we designed.
The Web Animations API
lets you create animations
from JavaScript, then offload
the animation calculations
to the browser, so
it can take care
of all the heavy
lifting for you.
And in many cases,
it can take advantage
of hardware
acceleration, so there's
very little work to
do for each frame.
Now what this means, it
enables proper hardware
accelerated animations to happen
via the use of a JavaScript
API, but without the
slowdown from recalculating
lots of stuff each frame.
This is something we didn't have
before, which is pretty cool,
huh?
I know what you're thinking.
Yeah, but we already
have CSS animations
that are hardware-accelerated.
Right, well that's true.
And by unifying
everything, we extend
the reach of hardware
acceleration.
The Web Animations design
brings together CSS animations,
transitions, SVG animation, and
JavaScript-created animations
all into one thing.
In fact, the Web
Animations engine
is currently used to run both
CSS animations and transitions
in Chrome.
You probably didn't even
notice when that happened,
and that's testament to how
seamlessly the Web Animations
engine integrates into browsers.
Now even better, is that
in addition to powering CSS
animations, you can
call element.animate,
which creates an animation
player object that's
used to interface
to the animation
internals inside the browser.
Now the object return
lets you query and modify
the running animation, so
you get decoupled running
of animation in the browser,
but retain the ability
to modify running
animation from JavaScript,
kind of the best of both worlds.
Now remember this?
The cool 3D globe is actually
built using web animations.
Bet you didn't guess that.
And it's just the
tip of the iceberg.
Here's another demo,
which shows how
you can manipulate a running
animation using input
like touch.
Now you can't build something
like this using CSS animation,
since there's no way to
dynamically manipulate
a running animation
once it's started.
But with Web Animations you can.
And here's another, which shows
true synchronization, something
almost everyone I've
talked to is excited about.
Web Animations are so cool,
and you can use them right now.
Not only does Chrome
have [INAUDIBLE]
support for web
animations, but we
launched an open source
implementation in JavaScript,
which let's you use the
API in any one browser.
That Polyfill let's you use
web animations right away,
and we're doing all of this
work in public at the W3C
to make sure all browser
vendors are on board.
So take a look at the
Polyfill, the demos,
hack through the code.
Make your site shine with
the most powerful animation
primitives available to
web developers today.
I know you'll blow
people's socks off.
I'm Alex Danilo, and I'm excited
to see what kinds of things
you'll build using
Web Animations.